Welcome back to Statistics 101.
Today, we do a case study.
The case study is based on data that you, the students, submitted
where on Facebook you all discussed my weight,
and you've all see me in this class
and a whopping 163 of you followed this very hidden Facebook discussion
and submitted your guesses.
Thanks to all of you, I now have a data set.
In my first study, I will treat your guesses as my data or sample
and somewhat abusing the nature of my own weight.
I treat my own weight as the hypothesis H0.
Technically speaking, this is a bit of an abuse.
We're not really testing  whether my own weight is incorrect,
but you can still use the same math and have a lot of fun.
Towards the end of this exercise, you will actually find out my weight.
Please don't tell anybody.
Here is the actual data that was submitted by all of you.
One of the really interesting findings here--some of you had some fun.
In the data, you find a guess 1  10²², which is about the weight of the planet Pluto in kilograms.
Then there are three counter guesses with -1,
which makes me suspect that these numbers were submitted by the same person.
Some of you think I weigh 0 whereas others think I weigh 1000 kg--as much as a car.
Thank you so much. Very kind of you.
Let's take this data, and I'll ask you the first quiz.